Hey, everybody.
I'm James Gunn.
I'm the co-CEO of D.C. studios.
So as many of you know,
DC has been disconnected in film
and television for a long time.
And it's one of, you know, our jobs,
mine and Peter's is to come in
and make sure the DCU is connected
in film,
television, gaming and animation,
that the characters are consistent,
played by the same actors,
and it works within one story.
And if something is outside of that,
like Matt Reeves, Batman
or Todd Phillips, Joker or Teen Titans go
that it is clearly labeled
as DC Elseworlds outside of the mainstream
DCU continuity.
Peter and I have gotten pretty lucky
in terms of the four projects
that are coming out over the next year.
First, we have Shazam Fury of the Gods.
Shazam has always been off
kind of in his own part of the DCU,
so he connects very well.
That moves directly into the Flash,
a fantastic movie
that I really love
that resets the entire DC universe.
Then to move into Blue Beetle,
a fantastic film about a kid
who's a marvelous part of the DCU,
and then into Aquaman two,
which leads directly
into our next few projects,
which I'm going to tell you about now.
So Peter and I, along
with a group of very talented writers,
have started to map out an 8 to 10 year
plan of what DC Studios will be in film.
Television and gaming.
This first chapter is called
Gods and Monsters.
Now this what I'm about to tell you
is a part of the first chapter.
It's not the entire first chapter.
The first project is Creature Commandos.
Creature Commandos is an animated series.
I've written all the episodes.
Something we're going to do
that's a little bit different in DC
is we're going to have characters move
into animation, out of animation, usually
having the same actor play their voice
as who plays them in live action.
The next project up is Waller.
This is a story of Amanda
Waller, played by Viola Davis.
Viola Davis is going to team up
with members of Team Peacemaker.
And this is a story
that's been created by Christal Henry,
who did Watchmen and Jeremy Carver,
who created the Doom Patrol.
It is a fantastic story
that's out of this world
and I can't wait for people to see it.
Okay.
Next up is the big one,
the true beginning of the DCU.
This is called Superman Legacy.
This is being written by me.
I'm in the middle of it
and I'm having a great time doing it.
And Superman will be released
into theaters July 11th, 2025.
Okay, The next thing is a big premiere HBO
television series called Lanterns.
This is a story of a couple of green
lanterns, Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan.
And we have a few other lanterns
peppered in there.
But this is really a terrestrial
based TV show, which is almost like true
detective with a couple of green lanterns
who are space cops
watching over precinct Earth.
In it, they discover a terrifying mystery
that ties into our larger
story of the DCU.
Next is a big movie called The Authority.
The authority is a passion
project of mine.
It's based on the marvelous
Wildstorm characters we are now
bringing into the DCU and will interact
with all of our primary DCU characters.
The Authority are a group of superheroes
who think the world is broken
and they want to fix it
by any means necessary.
I think it's a very different
look at superheroes.
We're doing a television
series called Paradise Lost.
Paradise Lost is a story of Paradise
Island, usually known
as Themyscira,
which is the birthplace of Wonder Woman.
It's almost like Game of Thrones
with Westeros,
but with all of the inhabitants
of Paradise Island.
The introduction of the DCU
as Batman is the brave and the Bold.
The Brave and the Bold is the story of
Batman and his actual son, Damian Wayne.
This is based on Grant Morrison's
great comic book run.
Damian Wayne is my favorite Robin.
He's a little assassin
who Batman tries to get in line.
And so this is the story
of the two of them
and the beginning
of sort of the Bat-Family in the DCU.
Next up is a TV series called Booster
Gold.
Booster Gold is one of comics
really popular cult heroes.
He is a fascinating guy.
He's a loser from the future
who uses future technology to come back
to present day and become a superhero
so that people will love him.
It is basically the superhero story
of imposter syndrome on an HBO Max series.
One of my favorite comic book series
from last year was Tom King's run
on Supergirl, Woman of Tomorrow.
And so we're going to turn that
into a big science fiction epic film now.
Superman is a guy who was sent to Earth
and raised by loving parents.
We're Supergirl in this story.
She is a character
who was raised on a chunk of Krypton.
She watched everybody around her
perish in some terrible way.
So she's a much more jaded character.
And that brings me to Swamp Thing.
The last thing we're going to talk about,
a very dark horror
story in the origins of the monster
who is Swamp Thing.
And although it's totally outside
of the rest of the DCU,
it will still feed
into the rest of the stories.
Anyway, those are the stories
that I can tell you about right now.
I've loved the DC characters
since I was a child.
They're incredibly important to me.
I knew that this was a once in a lifetime
opportunity to do something
very different.
One of the things that's very important
for me in all of these movies
and TV series
is that the director's vision
and the vision of the writers
and all of the creators is unique.
There's something special.
Storytelling is always king.
That's all that matters to us.
And I want to be true to those stories.
I want to be true to you guys
and really give you something different
than you've ever seen before.
And we thank you, everybody.
I appreciate you watching.
I hope this was exciting for you
because it's really exciting for me.
And I can't wait to start
to dive into these stories
with you guys on this grand adventure.
Thank you so much.
Welcome back, everyone. Is Charlie.
So James Gunn just announced
the new DC Phase one or DC Chapter
one, Gods and Monsters of their next
ten years of what they're calling the DCU,
The DC Universe.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of new movies.
They're rebooting everything.
There's a bunch of TV series
they announced.
If you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll be doing videos
for all these new TV series,
all the episodes, all the new movies
that they're going to be doing,
just like I do for all the other DC stuff.
But the first big thing is they're
calling it the DCU, not the DCU anymore.
And technically there'll be
a couple projects, like a couple of movies
and series before the true DCU is James
Gunn is calling.
It picks up
because like there are a couple of movies
coming out this year
that are still set in the Snyder verse,
like You have Shazam Fury of the Gods,
which is coming out really shortly.
I just did a bunch of trailer videos
for that.
Then we have the Flash movie
in the summer,
which is meant to reset the entire DCU
because they are doing
a version of Flashpoint.
Then the Blue Beetle movie will happen.
Everybody's been pretty hype about that.
And then Aquaman to the Lost Kingdom
at the end of the year,
and that'll be the end of the Snyder
verse Justice League line of movies.
There are a couple of DCU
Connected TV series
that will happen on HBO before that,
like Peacemaker Spin Offs and such.
I'll explain those in a second.
But the first proper movie
that they're releasing as part of the DCU
will be the new Superman movie
that he was hyping up a little while ago.
It's titled Superman Legacy Release Date
July 11th, 2025.
So that's like the official beginning
of the new James Gunn DCU chapter one.
They said it'd be heavily influenced
by all Stars Superman, which confirms why
he was reading that comic book and posted
the picture a couple of days ago.
It'll be a completely new actor.
It kind of explains why they are recasting
Henry Cavill because they want it
to be like a Superman year
or two or so earlier in his career.
Maybe not necessarily year
to the next big movie after that will be
their new Batman movie called Batman
The Brave and the Bold.
Everybody Remembering the Brave
and the Bold TV series.
It will be completely separate
from Robert Pattinson's Batman movie.
That'll be an Elseworlds story.
And they are calling anything
that's not directly connected
to what they're calling the DCU.
True Elseworlds
and it'll be titled as such.
They'll be recasting a different version
of Batman and it'll be a true live action.
Bat-Family focused mostly
on his relationship with Damian Wayne.
Like live action Damian Wayne.
Finally,
he said specifically it'd be influenced
on Grant Morrison's run,
where he introduced
Damian Wayne and called Damian
his favorite robin of all the robins.
But he said Bat-Family.
So that means that Nightwing
is probably in it.
Tim Drake is also probably in it somehow,
probably some of the other characters.
It's a very big Bat-Family they announced
they're doing a new Supergirl movie
and it's called Supergirl
Woman of Tomorrow.
Based on Tom King's recent run,
you can actually go read that comic book
right now.
It'll be inspired by that.
They didn't say if it be the Sasha Collar
version of Supergirl
that they're introducing
in The Flash movie
or a completely new one.
But they made
it sound like it's
going to be a completely new one,
and they will
just recast the new Supergirl
and they get ready for that movie.
But it won't come till well
after the new Superman movie.
They're doing a new Swamp Thing movie is
like a true horror movie inside the DCU.
They'll totally be very different
from the other movies,
but it'll still be connected to the larger
DCU story that they're moving forward.
They're doing a movie
based on the Authority,
which is actually a Wildstorm team,
and it's primarily
meant to bring the Wildstorm characters
into the live action DCU
because they bought Jim Lee's Wildstorm
Comics a long time ago when they hired
Jim Lee or technically rehired him.
This is like 20 plus years ago.
Those Wildstorm
characters have kind of been
in this weird, nebulous type of continuity
where they tried to bring Wildstorm
and integrated with the DC Universe.
Now they're doing that in live action
form.
A lot of their characters
are meant to be analogs
of Main DC characters,
so we'll see how they treat them.
But like James Gunn says, they're a team
that thinks the world is broken
and they're trying to fix it.
For all the big TV series
that they're doing,
they're all meant to be big budget
HBO series.
Kind of like Peacemaker was the first new
one as part of the DCU will be the New
Green Lantern series called Lanterns,
and it takes place mostly on Earth.
It's going to be a buddy cop series
like True Detective in the DC Universe
with Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart.
If you remember several years ago
when they announced
they were doing a Green Lantern Corps
movie, people are like,
Why don't you just do True
Detective in space?
Turns out they're doing it.
But as a big budget HBO series supposedly
this is meant to be completely different
from what Greg Berlanti was doing
with his Green Lantern series
with a bunch of other green lanterns.
There will be other lanterns on it,
he said.
But I think creatively
they're just like a bunch
of different people working on it. Now.
There'll be a Peacemaker spinoff
focused on Amanda Waller.
He teased that a while ago.
It just called Waller.
Right now,
it sounds like they're treating it
like Peacemaker Season two
because it spins out of Peacemaker
season one.
Most of the Peacemaker
characters will cross over into it.
I don't know if this means
that they're not doing
Peacemaker Season two
and they'll just do the Wallace series
or they're also doing Peacemaker
Season two.
He was really clear about that.
They're doing a Wonder Woman series,
but it doesn't star Wonder Woman.
It's called
Paradise Lost, and it'll be set before
Wonder Woman is born on Theme Obscura.
And it'll be kind of like Game of Thrones
in the DC Universe.
But on Paradise Island, Wonder
Woman was born about 5000 years ago.
So that gives you an idea for the timeline
of when things take place during it.
Now it kind of makes sense
why they couldn't do Wonder Woman three
Why they canceled that movie.
And Patty Jenkins said there was no way
forward for the storyline.
There was no way for them to work it out
because their next big story with Wonder
Woman takes place way before she was born.
They're doing a Booster Gold series.
They've been talking about
doing a booster gold project,
a movie, a TV series for a long time now.
It's cool to see him finally get his due,
and they're doing an animated Creature
Commando series with characters
that will also cross over
into live action.
Kind of like Marvel's
What If series, where the characters
are played by the movie actors as well.
Creature Commandos was a team
put together during World
War Two of a bunch of monsters
called Project M.
It started out
with Frankenstein's monster,
a vampire in a werewolf,
and then in present day,
they just continue cycling the roster
with a bunch of different monsters.
They did address the fate of Ezra miller
because there's been a lot of questions
about whether or not
they're getting rid of him
or are they going to recast
with a brand new flash.
They say they're basically waiting
to announce what's happening with him
until after
he potentially makes it through rehab
and a lot of his legal troubles.
What I think that actually means is
they're just waiting till after
the Flash movie comes out to announce
that they're going to recast him
like long term.
I do expect them to recast Ezra Miller
But that's the big news.
Obviously.
Huge thing is they starting off
with a brand new Superman movie
and there's a couple holdover projects
that are still kind of loosely connected
to the Snyder verse.
But for the most part,
this year is the last like real year
of the DCU Snyder verse line of movies.
And they're still doing the Robert
Pattinson Batman movies, the Batman two
is coming out in a couple of years.
They're still doing Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker two coming out in a couple of years.
But like I said, that stuff
they'll treat like Elseworlds,
but they're not going to start
doing a ton of Elseworlds stuff.
Like there'll be a couple things here
and there.
Elseworlds But for the most part,
the whole idea here is that James
Gunn, as he said in his video here,
especially like at the very end,
is that they wanted everything
to be connected.
Everyone also be sure to post
all your reactions in the comments below.
Like there's
so many things to react to here.
So obviously there's still
lots of questions,
lots of huge characters
that they didn't talk about,
like what's going to happen with Aquaman
because Jason
Momoa made it sound like he's
going to continue being Aquaman,
but he didn't mention Aquaman
or The Flash, for instance,
or even the Shazam characters
or Blue Beetle for that matter.
What's going to happen to them
after the events of their movies?
A lot of that,
I think they're just waiting to announce
so that they don't throw water
on any of the big releases
like they want the movies
to earn as much money as possible.
So like, okay, we'll just kind of
put them to be determined.
Ultimately, though,
I think a lot of them will be recast.
There will probably be a couple of
characters that will continue on, though.
Jason Momoa seems very confident
that he will continue as Aquaman,
but also other characters
like Lobo, for instance.
I've already done
a couple other videos about the projects
that they announced so far
and what's happening with
some of the other people like Henry Cavill
doing his new Warhammer series.
You can click here for that new Henry
Cavill Warhammer trailer and learn
what's going on with him
the next couple of years
and click here for my brand new flash
trailer and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.